what kind of dancing would we do like
swing dancing ballroom dancing i can do
a little salsa just a little bit so
[Music]
it's not very good but you know it'll
work we can work on that
[Applause]
[Music]
hi i'm jess i am 21. so i
only started getting into fashion like
my senior year of high school i had to
buy all my own clothes so i got really
into thrifting i work part-time as an
environmental consultant and then right
now i'm studying for the lsat so i can
apply to law schools what i tend to lean
towards is like
tyler the creator kind of if a guy can
pull off a suit i'm also very into that
too maybe into grunge but also business
casual that would be the perfect man
[Music]
i'm like not a huge shoe person in
general and they're probably like the
last thing i think about when it comes
to an outfit but they say that you can
tell the most about someone from their
shoes
okay contestant number two i like those
shoes a lot i would wear those shoes
yeah
also um contested number four those are
pretty nice i'm curious what's gonna
accompany the rest of those i can't
really tell too much off the bat so
what kind of music is everyone into my
favorite genre is probably like rap like
kanye new album danda i also listen to
like pop like ariana grande it's like
100 gex
i'm a producer i make a lot of music
from different genres anything from like
reggae to hip hop to house music
i'm a big r b guy but i definitely like
to mix it up with alternative music as
well
i was into a lot of indie rock my
favorite bands were sad girl and a man
called maxiel also a lot of like old
crony music like frank sinatra dean
martin bobby darin i'd say a favorite
band rolling stones and favorite artists
otis redding
i like thundercat and prince
prince is obviously the best musician of
all time so you know there's that
okay let me let me go back let me go
back
i'm going to have to
eliminate
very sadly
contestant number one
hi
hi i'm sorry you your outfit is amazing
though i love it
what happened to your face
oh it's just nelly inspired oh oh okay
well this is cool
[Music]
can i look now
oh okay contestant number five is not
what i was expecting at all
i don't know i i just expected him first
to be wearing like pants or like
something more athletic i like it though
i like the colors a lot
i'm very into it condensate number three
is kind of what i expected i also liked
his music choices too so very promising
can i ask everyone a question now
okay where would we go on our first date
and what would we be doing definitely
love to go on a drive probably somewhere
like near the coast you know get that
like nice ocean breeze afterwards i
would love to like show you some of my
music and maybe cook you something if
you're done okay so um i like to go out
to like overlooks and in cliffs and just
kind of like watch the stars or just
just uh chill in the car and then talk
and like really get to know you okay so
for me i consider myself like a big
romantic definitely gonna take you out
to dinner maybe a place i haven't tried
before or somewhere that i know that's
really good and maybe go like dancing or
what kind of dancing would we do like
swing dancing ballroom dancing i can do
a little salsa just a little bit so
[Music]
it's not very good but you know it'll
work we can work on that i'd probably
take you for a ride out to my favorite
spot on angel's crest highway and we
probably would have a picnic there and
after then an art museum what would you
drive us to the spot in
a motorcycle if that's okay yeah i've
never been on the back of a motorcycle
actually there's always a first i would
choose a drive-in movie i drive a truck
so i've got a pretty impressive driving
movie set up air mattress blankets
pillows picnic all that all set up
preferably a horror movie if you're into
that
oh
i only had one
okay i had to rethink now
i'm gonna eliminate contestant number
two
[Music]
just
hi
nice to meet you nice to meet you sorry
your answer is just not just
i'm jess yeah feels the answers it's
okay yeah all right
so now it's going to be contestant
number two
yeah
sorry no you two are good i'm jeff i'm
jess i love your outfit thank you i
appreciate it and about the sustainable
fashion i work at a thrift store really
yeah so i'm like that would have been a
power couple
[Music]
i feel like the tops definitely match
the pants i still really like the outfit
on the end you have a really cool style
yeah i like the the leather jacket goes
with the motorcycle goes with the rock
music so i'm making sense now
yeah
oh nothing about me i mean
it looks very like comfy i see maybe a
little bit of a chain i like that where
do you see yourself in five years i am
leaving in about six months to asia i'm
starting a business project in the
philippines with my friend we are
developing affordable housing for pretty
much anyone around the world to be able
to vacation i'm trying to you know make
it more accessible for people to be able
to visit beautiful places oh that's a
great answer yeah it's super sweet i
like that
probably tattooing and traveling at the
same time currently i'm doing the tattoo
apprenticeship down in oc
hopefully that will give me opportunity
to travel and work at the same time what
got you into tattoos or what was your
first tattoo
well what got me into tattooing was art
in general and i've been drawing all my
life i have a degree in fine arts i just
figured that's a way to make money and
do what i love and for a tattoo i was 17
and it was in new york city and i got a
skull on the inside of my bicep
i do not have any tattoos right now but
i do want to get one eventually
i'm pretty stationary compared to
everybody else i suppose i would like to
either open up my own dealership or
start brokering out cars personally cars
are my passions so what's your dream car
oh that's a hard that's i'm a big
mercedes-benz guy i worked for them for
about four years so
maybe
i would say maybe an sls going
[Music]
i think
the first person i'm going to eliminate
is contestant number two
hi i'm jess nice to meet you tomorrow
pleasure to meet you hey what is it
tomorrow tomorrow pleasure to meet you
thank you i like yours too thank you
give me 30 seconds
this is really tough
i feel like i like both their outfits in
different ways so now i gotta think back
to the answers
i'm gonna
eliminate contestant number two
i'm so sad about it though
it's all good hi i'm jess nice to meet
you jess quinn quinn nice to meet you
too so i was very narrow
very close
[Music]
hey i'm jess hey what's up nice meeting
you what's your name taryn i'm honestly
really excited about what you're doing
in the future with sustainable fashion
thank you i liked what you were going to
do like your plan for five years i was
very into it awesome i think it was your
first date that like really got me
because it sounds like fun i think
there's definitely like a lot of
elements that i do like the jewelry i've
never gone before before but i kind of
like it glad i'm spicing it up yeah you
are spicing it up
i mean let's get married oh yeah okay i
have rings oh you have multiple yours
are cooler than mine too we're getting
married
then go for a drive into the distance
yeah into the sunset
not on a motorcycle obviously